we're told to complete the ratio table
to convert the units of measure from
hours to weeks or weeks to hours so we
here we see here they've told us already
that there's a hundred sixty eight hours
for every one week one way to think
about it as the ratio of hours for every
week is 168 to one and then they
calculate well if we have one thousand
one hundred seventy six hours how many
weeks is that going to be so pause this
video and see if you can figure it out
let's see to go from 168 to 1176 what do
we have to multiply by so let's see do
we that looks like we might be
multiplying by seven let me try that out
so 168 times seven is equal to 8 times 7
is 56 6 times 7 is 42 plus 5 is 47 and
then 1 times 7 plus 4 is indeed 1176 so
we multiplied by 7 we multiply the
number of hours by 7 so that means we're
gonna have 7 times as many weeks so 1
times 7 is just that is 7 weeks now what
about a situation where we have 3 weeks
how many hours is that going to be well
we are multiplying our weeks by 3 so we
would want to multiply our hours we
would want to multiply our hours times 3
so 168 times 3 8 times 3 is 24 6 times 3
is 18 plus 2 is 20 and then 1 times 3 is
3 plus 2 is 5 so that would be 504 hours
let's do another example so here they
tell us the double number lines show the
ratio of yards to miles so the ratio of
yards to miles it looks like we have
three thousand five hundred and twenty
yards for every two miles for every 2
miles and you see that on this double
number line right over here then they
say how many yards are in five miles so
why don't you pause this video and try
to figure it out well the way my
brain wants to do it is well let's just
think about how many yards are in each
mile so if the ratio is 3,500 22 - well
what how could I rewrite this ratio so
it is how many yards for every one mile
so to go from two to one I am dividing
by two so I would want to divide this by
two as well so 2 goes into 2 goes into
3520 let's see 2 goes into 3 one time 1
times 2 is 2 you subtract you bring down
the 5 2 goes into 15 7 times 7 times 2
is 14 subtract we have 1 bring down that
2 2 goes into 12 6 times 6 times 2 is 12
and we subtract no remainder but then
we're gonna have one more 0 here because
we'd bring down that 0 we say 2 goes
into 0 0 times 0 times 2 is 0 and we
have no remainder and so this is 1760 so
we could put that here on our double
number lines so if we have one mile that
is 1,760 yards now they're asking about
5 miles so 3 4 5 so we have 5 miles what
is the number of yards well if you
multiply by 5 here you're also going to
multiply by 5 right over there
so what's 1760 times 5 let's just figure
it out 1760 times 5 5 times 0 is 0 5
times 6 is 30
regroup that 3 cuz it's really 3
hundreds 5 times 7 is 35 plus 3 is 38 5
times 1 is 5 plus 3 is 8 so there you go
eight thousand eight hundred yards eight
thousand eight hundred yards let's do a
few more examples here we're told
they're nine hundred fourteen point four
millimeters in a yard there are three
feet in a yard how many millimeters are
in a foot okay so one way to think about
it you could say there's nine hundred
fourteen point four millimeters per yard
or you could say
fourteen point four millimeters per
three feet since three feet and a yard
is the same thing so if you want to know
per foot you would just divide both of
these by three so let's do that and I'll
just do it in a different color here 3
goes into 914 0.4 3 goes into 9 3 times
3 times 3 is 9 subtract we get a zero
bring down the 1 3 goes into 1 0 times 0
times 3 is 0 subtract you get a 1 bring
down that 4 3 goes into 14 4 times we're
gonna have this decimal right over here
4 times 3 is 12 you subtract and then so
you get a 2 bring down this 4 you get a
24 and lucky for us 3 goes perfectly
into 24 8 times 8 times 3 is 20 24 24
you subtract and we have no remainder so
we have 300 and 4 point 8 millimeters
for every foot let's do one last example
Yukie bought a pound of confetti for $12
what is the price in dollars per ounce
of confetti
there are 16 ounces in one pound so
pause this video and see if you can
figure it out so let's just write this
out in words so it's 12 dollars per
pound of confetti so you could view this
as $12 per 16 ounces 16 ounces of
confetti and so if we want it per ounce
so you could view this as a 12 to 16
ratio but we want to say something to 1
ratio so if you say per 1 ounce
well we're dividing by 16 there so we
would want to divide by 16 as well so
this is going to be 12 divided by 16 so
12 divided by well that let me write it
over here so 12 divided by 16 is the
same thing as 3/4 just divide both of
them by
for and so this is 0.75 or 75 cents 75
cents per ounce or seventy five
hundredths of a dollar per ounce so 0.75
and we're done